BORIS: Today with
us is Roberto Trotta
with his book, "The
Edge of the Sky."
It's going to be an interesting
cosmology talk for those of you
who would like to learn
more about cosmology
but in simple words.
So let me just give you
a brief introduction.
Roberto Trotta is a
theoretical cosmologist
in the astrophysics group of
the Imperial College in London.
He has held research positions
at the University of Geneva
and the University of Oxford,
as well as visiting positions
at the African Institute for
Mathematical Sciences in Cape
Town, the Institut Astrophysique
de Paris, and the University
of California at Santa Barbara.
One of the world's leading
figures in astrostatistics,
and new discipline focusing on
the use of statistical methods
to solve problems in
cosmology and astrophysics,
he has published more
than 50 scientific papers,
contributed to two books,
and received numerous awards
for his research, including the
Michelson Prize of Case Western
Reserve University, the Lord
Kelvin Award of the British
Association for the
Advancement of Science,
and a public engagement
fellowship by the Science
and Technology Facilities
Council in the UK.
Please join me in welcoming
Roberto to Google.
ROBERTO TROTTA:
Thank you, Boris.
And good afternoon, everyone.
And thanks for being here today.
I'm very pleased
to be here today
in such an amazing place
full of computer people who
can search the entire worldwide
computer to answer all
of your questions and can draw
a picture of the streets in
[INAUDIBLE].
And now, so I hear,
you're even building
cars that can drive alone.
So this is really the
perfect place for me
to talk about my new book,
"The Edge of the Sky."
This book came out of a
straightforward simple idea,
that it should be
possible to talk
about very hard things
in a straightforward way
that all people can understand.
The problem with student
people like myself, you see,
is that sometimes we get
carried away and speak
about our work using
words in a tone
that only other student
people can understand.
This makes it not
possible to have
a conversation with other
people, people like you.
After a little
while, your eyes will
begin to stare into empty
space, and you'll probably
walk away as soon as you
can with a silent sigh,
happy to have escaped.
A way to avoid all that is by
talking with only the most used
ten hundred words
in this tongue.
When I heard about
this, I thought
it could be fun to use it
to explain the [INAUDIBLE].
And this is what
my book is about,
and what this here is about.
I would like to
share with you some
of the ideas behind the
book and the story of how
this slightly crazy
idea became reality.
So you might have thought that
this was a little strange,
perhaps.
And you might have thought,
well this is down to the fact
that I spent way too
much time in Britain.
And so of course we know that
the United States and Britain
are two nations which are
separated by the same language.
But actually, that's
not the reason
why this sounded a
little bit weird.
The reason why
this was different
is because it was written
using only the most common ten
hundred words in
English, which is
the idea behind "The
Edge of the Sky."
As so I just wanted to
give you a little bit
of a sense for what
this language is about,
and how it actually
can change the way
we communicate with each other.
So before I go on,
I'd like to ask
you to keep your phones on in
case you have switched them
off-- I hope not-- and
please join the conversation
on Twitter by getting in touch
with me with my Twitter handle
and #theedgeofthesky hashtag.
So let me take a
step back and go back
to the '60s, at a time
when very little was known
about the universe
and we didn't have
all of the great data and
the great capabilities
to observe the sky and the
universe as we do today.
These two gentlemen came up
with a wonderful discovery
in 1965, Penzias and Wilson.
They were working at
Bell Labs in New Jersey,
not far away from
Princeton in fact.
And they had a big
microwave antenna
with which they were looking
into doing some experiments
in microwave
communication, early days
still before satellite
communication.
They were trying to bounce off
the microwaves of some passing
satellites, trying to
communicate long distance using
microwaves.
But the problem was that they
couldn't make their antenna
work because they kept picking
up a very strange background
noise, a noise that they didn't
know where it was coming from.
And they tried very, very
hard to get rid of the noise
and they couldn't.
At some point then they got in
touch with a team of scientists
at Princeton who were actually
trying to build an antenna
to look for this kind of noise.
And this microwave noise,
this microwave light
was none other than the light
echo from the Big Bang itself.
Unbeknownst to them, they'd
discover the [INAUDIBLE]
radiation from the Big Bang.
And so in 1965 they
came out with this paper
here, a paper that in
only one and a half pages
talks about this
momentous discovery.
And the title of the
paper is "The Measurement
of Excess Antenna
Temperature at 4080 Mc/s".
And that's not a great
title, to be fair.
What they were trying to say
is, we have found evidence
that the universe
had a beginning.
We've discover the luminous
echo from the Big Bang.
But this title is kind
of jargony and not really
accessible to anybody,
even them to be fair.
They didn't actually know
what they discovered.
It was the Princeton
team that told them
what the discovery mean
And sometimes in
communicating the science,
scientific papers are
perhaps not the best way
of getting the message across.
So you might think 1965
was early days still
in science and astrophysics.
And certainly,
science communication
wasn't as developed
as it is today.
And so things must have
improved in the meantime.
So let's have a look at another
momentous discovery in my field
in astrophysics,
a discovery that
was worthy of a Nobel
Prize for physics in 2011.
And here is a paper in 1999,
published in the "Astrophysical
Journal" with a title that
goes as follows, "Measurements
of Omega and Lambda from 42
High-Redshift Supernovae".
Now, wherever you see Greek
letters in scientific papers,
and specifically
astrophysical papers,
that's a sign that
we the scientists are
trying to be clever and smart,
and trying to make it look
like as if we know a lot about
what we're talking about,
but we don't necessarily.
And so the paper
goes on [INAUDIBLE]
"we report measurement of
the mass density [INAUDIBLE]
and cosmological constant
density omega and lambda
of the universe,
based on the analysis
of 42 type 1a supernovae
discovered by the supernova
[INAUDIBLE] project,
et cetera, et cetera.
And it goes on, and on, and on.
And so what they're trying
to say with this paper is,
we've discovered evidence
that the universe
is expanding in
an accelerated way
and is being ripped
apart by an unknown force
that we call dark energy.
And none of that
really comes through
if you read the paper, or the
abstract, or indeed the title.
So that was 1999.
You might think, well
actually nowadays,
21st century with
all the social media
and so on, communicating
exciting science
must have become so much easier.
So let's have a look
at another discovery,
another Nobel Prize for physics,
this time at the large hadron
colider, the particle
accelerator at CERN in Geneva.
And here the title
is, "Observation
of a new Boson on a Mass of
125 GeV with the CMS Experiment
at the LHC".
Now you can see now that there's
no longer a list of authors.
There's only a CMS collaboration
tag as a list of authors.
That's because
science has become
so big in the
meantime, two people
from Nobel Prize
for physics in 1965
the discoverers of the
microwave background,
about 25 or 30 people
on the previous paper
for the supernova type
1a dark energy discovery.
And now the CMS collaboration,
about 5,000 scientists
working on these big projects.
So that's how big
science is nowadays.
And how do they
present these results?
Well, they say results are
presented-- no we go over
to passive form to make it
look a bit more impersonal
and objective.
"Results are presented from
searches for the standard model
Higgs boson proton-proton
collisions at square root of s
equals 7 and 8 TeV in the
Compact Muon Solenoid".
A compact muon solenoid
is-- [INAUDIBLE]
is like a five
story high building
full of instrumented iron and
other computerized detectors.
That's what "compact"
means nowadays in physics.
And so the compact muon
solenoid [INAUDIBLE]
MHC using data
samples corresponding
to [INAUDIBLE] of up to
5.1 inverse [INAUDIBLE]
at 7 [INAUDIBLE] and 5.3 inverse
[INAUDIBLE] at 8 [INAUDIBLE]
et cetera, et cetera.
And so what are
they trying to say?
They're trying to
tell us that they've
discovered the God
particle, the Higgs boson,
the particle that gives
mass to all other particles.
And so you can see that
scientific research papers are
not perhaps the very best places
to look for the excitement
that all of this
great science actually
is about and the
great discoveries
that this science is supposed to
be communicating to the public
as well.
And fair enough, those
are scientific papers
which are written for
specialists by specialists
and are targeting a very
restricted audience.
But as a scientist
working in this field,
my quest has been
for many years now
to find ways of talking about
these very exciting science
topics in more accessible,
direct, and exciting ways
to communicate with the
public and the educated public
and people who are interested
in these discoveries in a more
effective way.
And try to find ways of not
only talking about the science
that those great discoveries
are about, but also
about having a
dialogue with people,
breaking down the
communication barriers,
the jargon such as those
examples that we just saw
is raising in our
discussion between ourselves
and the public, the
scientists and the public.
So my work in
astrophysics and cosmology
is about using big data
and astrostatistical--
that is to say advanced
statistical methods--
to analyze those big data
and trying to understand them
in terms of what they mean
for the fundamental nature
and fundamental theories
of our universe.
So big questions, such as what
is the nature of dark energy,
dark matter, stuff that we don't
know in the universe that's
dark and invisible, and
yet is responsible for 95%
of the universe?
What does the
universe come from?
What will be its final fate?
So all of those
questions are usually
exciting to us the scientists,
but also the public at large.
How do we talk about
those discoveries
in a way that's more meaningful
and more interactive, and not
full of jargon?
So for a decade now,
I've been looking
for different ways
of communicating
this exciting science
with the public.
And I've tried different things.
I've tried using food
to talk about cosmology.
So explaining the
Hubble expansion,
the expansion of the
universe in terms of pizza
dough, for example.
Here you see an
example of our galaxy,
the Milky Way, here, and a model
of the universe expanding here
with other galaxies-- the other
bits of olives expanding out
as time goes on.
In this sense, you can
see the universe expands
and all galaxies move away
from every other galaxy.
That's a perfect 2-D model
of the universe which
you can make in
your own kitchen.
And it works fairly well.
You can see this
little yardstick, which
is made of a piece
of bean, I think.
And you can see
that distances grow.
And between galaxies here,
it's one bean unit, one
and a half, two bean units.
It works.
So that's a funny
way of engaging
with the public,
because it's hands on.
It's stuff that you can
do in your own kitchen.
And I've taken it
to the next stage,
and I've tried putting
on a cosmic cookery show.
And I'm cooking pancakes
with a live audience,
and because this is in the
UK where health and safety
laws are very strict, you can
see I even have a little fire
extinguisher at hand just
in case things go wrong,
as they do when you
experiment with a microwave
and then burn chocolate
in a microwave.
There's lots of
smoke coming out.
It's very spectacular,
and it's fun.
It's a way of engaging
the public, as well,
in a way that's a
little bit different.
I work with artists
and designers
to build the artwork that is
inspired by cosmological ideas.
Here is, for
example, a structure,
a creation that
conceptualizes redshift
in a slightly different way.
And I've worked with
architects and others
to create things like
this pinball machine that
was exhibited at the
[INAUDIBLE] a few years ago
that represented some sort
of potential energy idea.
It would be a long
story, probably
a story for another talk.
But the point is that I've
tried different avenues.
But I was looking
always for something
that was a little different.
I was looking for something that
was more immediate and creative
in a way that would
involve language as well.
And perhaps all along I
had in the back of my mind
this great example that goes
back to Ernest Hemingway
apparently.
I don't know whether
the story is true,
but it's attributed to him.
And the story is that
Hemingway was one day sitting
around the table
with some friends.
And those friends challenged
him to construct a novel
in a very short number
of words, just six works.
And he said, yes of
course, I can do it.
And a bet was made, and
he accepted the bet.
And then he sat there for a few
minutes and thought about it.
And he came up with
what has become
known as a form
of flash fiction.
And the novel that he wrote
in only six words is this.
"For sale: baby
shoes, never worn."
That's quite intense.
Six words only, there's
and entire world
behind these six words.
And there's lots
that remains unsaid,
but there's lots that stimulates
perhaps your imagination.
There's more to just the words.
There's another layer, and
you or us as the readers
are stimulated to think, what
else is the story going on
beyond those words and
behind those words?
And so I was looking
for something like that.
Some way of
condensing all we know
about the universe,
all there is,
in a simple yet imaginative
and creative way.
Now of course in physics, if you
think about physics and science
in general, we have
ways of condensing
a variety of phenomena
down in very simple terms.
So for example, if we
think about electricity
and magnetism,
those are phenomena
that are ubiquitous
in our everyday lives,
from power generation to all
sorts of electrical tools
in our households, to
electricity, and lights,
and telecommunication, and power
again, turbine generation here.
All of those things are aspects
of the electrical and magnetic
phenomena that very
much rule our lives,
or certainly have a
big part in our lives.
And yet all of this
variety of phenomena
are down to one single force,
the electromagnetic force which
can be described in physics
using a very condensed and very
simple, in a sense, expression.
A mathematical description which
boils down to this one equation
here.
Now I won't unpack this one
equation for you necessarily,
but I just want to highlight
how physics in general
is a quest for simplicity,
a quest for beauty,
a quest for symmetry.
Although things are
condensed into equations
such as this one, which is a
compact form of writing down
the four Maxwell equations
that-- as you might remember
from high school or university
if you encountered those
before-- the four
Maxwell's equations
describe all of the
electromagnetical phenomena
that we know about.
And they can all be written
down in one simple line,
in one single equation,
this equation here.
But the probem, of course
it that with this language,
it takes-- in this
form, it will take
probably a major in
physics understand
what this form means.
It is not a way of
presenting electromagnets
that we're using for our
undergrad physics students.
And so while there is beauty,
simplicity, symmetry, elegance
even in equations such as
this, this is not something
that we can use to
communicate with the public,
because of this
not only language
barrier but also
technical knowledge gap.
So we need to go
beyond this and find
ways of unpacking the beauty
and elegance of equations
such as this in a way
that's more immediate, more
understandable.
Here is another
example, the universe
with all its plethora of
phenomena from galaxies
such as the Andromeda
galaxy-- our neighbor galaxy--
or binary stars that
eat up each other
and then explode
in a big explosion
at the end of their life, to
the distribution of clusters
in the sky and the dark
matter structures perhaps
as well in the universe.
All of this is largely
governed by gravity.
And gravity, as
Einstein told us in 1915
with the discovery of the
general theory of relativity,
all of this can be written
down in one simple, elegant
equation, which is this,
Einstein's equation.
It's a beautiful equation,
again very elegant, very dense,
very compact in a sense.
And this equation is
telling us on this side
here that the shape
space time-- which
is described by
this symbol here--
is equal to the matter energy
content on that side here.
And so what this
equation says in words
is that space time is bent
by the presence of mass.
And mass reacts to the shape
of space time in its movement
through space.
And so for example,
what this equation tells
us is that gravity is not the
source like Newton thought
and like we learned in school.
Gravity is a consequence of
the geometry of space time.
And so when we
see the moon going
around the Earth in a
circular orbit-- or so
we think-- it's
not a force that's
keeping this satellite on track.
What's happening is
the mass of the Earth
is changing the shape
of space time around it,
and therefore the moon is
going in a straight path.
Only a straight path in a bent
space time looks like a circle.
And this is all beautifully
condensed into this one
equation.
And so I was looking
for ways of expressing
all of that in a way that would
be understandable to people who
have not studied physics but
are nonetheless fascinated,
interested by all
of this phenomena.
After all, the
cosmos is perhaps one
of the biggest
questions in science.
Questions such as, where
does the universe come from?
What will the destiny
of the universe be?
What is the fundamental
nature of reality?
These are questions that concern
us all at some very high level.
But nonetheless,
these are questions
that fascinate the
public at large.
So how do we talk about them
in a more immediate way?
So I was thinking about
all of those things.
And I'd been thinking about all
of them for a long time now.
And then one day I
came across something
that was really impressing
and inspirational.
I came across the Up Goer Five.
Now, I probably don't need to
explain to this audience what
XKCD is, but in case you
are the new Google employee
that just landed
from Mars and haven't
heard of XKCD before, I'll
just say a few words about it.
XKCD is this wildly popular--
geeky, frankly-- geeky cartoon
on the web, which
is characterized
by a very peculiar
sense of humor.
Sometimes those cartoons
are about physics,
and I get some of those.
Often they're about
computer science,
and I don't get many
of those I must admit.
And sometimes
they're very funny,
and sometimes
they're just targeted
at specific communities, and
so you don't get them all.
But Randall Munroe, the creator
of XKCD a year and a half
ago or so came up with this
idea of the Up Goer Five.
As you can see, the Up Goer Five
is none other than the Saturn V
moon rocket with one
difference, with one twist.
And the twist was
that Randall thought
of labeling this
picture of the Saturn V
with limiting all of the
parts with only the most used
ten hundred words in
the English language.
And so of course he couldn't
call it the Saturn V moon
rocket, because "moon" is
not of the thousand words,
and "rocket" is not one
of the thousand words,
and "Saturn's" not one
of the thousand words.
And so he named it
the Up Good Five.
And instead of calling
it, NASA's Up Goer Five,
he called it US Space
Team's Up Goer Five.
It's funny.
You should go through
the various parts.
There are bits and pieces
that read like-- for example,
here the escape module,
it's called the thing
to help people escape really
fast if there's a problem
and everything is on fire
so they decide not to go
into space, which is a fair--
it's a good description,
isn't it?
And if you go down,
down here there's
the oxygen tank called air
for burning and breathing.
This part had a very big
problem once, true that.
And then here the
lunar module is
the part that flies down to
the other world with two people
inside, and so on and so forth.
So it was a fun and
interesting idea.
And people picked it
up on the internet,
some people put
together a web page
where they challenged
users of that web page
to write up their job
description using this thousand
words format.
And so I tried that--
one day I came across it
and I tried that.
I spent half an
hour trying write up
my job as an astrophysicist.
And it was very hard, much
harder than you would imagine,
because many, many of words
that you'd like to use
are not on the list.
And it was quite surprising
to go through the list and see
which words are on
it and which aren't.
And so I wrote up that piece,
maybe a couple paragraphs.
It took me maybe the best
part of an hour to do so.
I put it on my website and
then I forgot about it.
And then a few
weeks later, I was
giving a talk in
the White Building
in East London, which is an art
venue near the Olympic Park.
And the person who introduced me
said a few words about myself.
And they said that I
also had written my job
up using the thousand
most used words.
And they left it at that.
I gave my talk.
And at the end of the Q&A
session with the audience,
somebody asked a
question about, what
was this business
with 1,000 words.
I didn't understand what
this thing is about,
can you explain?
And so because I had
it on my computer,
I read it allowed
to the audience.
And I read out what I'd
written in this format.
And this was what I had.
I study tiny bits of matter
that are all around us that we
cannot see, which
we call dark matter.
We know dark matter is out
there because it changes
the way other big
far away things move
such a stars and star crowds.
We want to understand
what dark matter is
made of because it could tell
us about where everything
around us came from and
what will happen next.
To study dark
matter, people like
me use big things that have
taken lots of money, thought,
and people to build.
Some of the things
fly way above us.
Some are deep inside the ground.
Some are large rings that make
tiny pieces of mobile matter
kiss each other as they fly
around very, very fast, almost
as fast as light.
We hope that we can hear
the whisper of dark matter
if we listen very carefully.
We take all the whispers from
all the [INAUDIBLE] things
and we put them together
in our computers.
We use big computers
to do this, as there
are lots and lots of tiny
whispers we need to look at.
I go to places
all over the world
to talk to other people
like me, as together we
can think better
and work faster.
Together perhaps, we can
even find new better ways
to listen to dark matter.
Most of them are good people,
and after we've talked,
we go out and have a
drink, and talk some more.
So I read this aloud,
and I was astonished
by the reaction of the
public because everybody
was taken aback by this format.
They weren't expecting
it to be quite like that.
And so I got a very warm round
of applause, which was actually
much better than the applause
that I got for my talk.
I was encouraged by
it, because I thought,
well actually
there is something.
Perhaps this format is just
what I was looking for.
Perhaps in this thousand words
there is something hidden
and it would be an
interesting and fun challenge
to try to describe the
entirety of all there is.
Of course, universe
is not on the list,
so the universe became the all
there is with this format here.
And so that's what
I started doing.
I started sitting
down, and I tried
to see whether this format
could be expanded beyond three
paragraphs to book length.
And again, I was very
lucky because a few months
after that, in April, I
had time to spend here
at the University of
California Santa Barbara.
And that is the view
out of my office window.
So The Edge of the Sky,
the title of the book,
probably came out
of this moment here
that I was so lucky to have
a three month long research
stay at Santa Barbara.
And so I had time and
intellectual freedom
to do research, of course,
but also to devote myself
a little bit to
exploring this format
and to explore the
thousand words idea.
And to see whether
it could be stretched
to encompass the all there is.
And so all of a
sudden I find myself
battling against this
self-imposed lexicon,
this straitjacket.
There were many,
many words that I
would have liked to use to
describe the universe which
I didn't have.
And so I started banging
my head against it.
I wanted to explain in entire
history and entire knowledge
of the universe, but without
using the word "universe".
Without using the word
"gravity", or "telescope",
or "particle", or "earth".
"Planet" was not on
the list. "Energy",
so there wasn't even "energy".
"Cosmos", of course not.
"Big Bang" wasn't on the list.
"Galaxy", "scientist".
I couldn't talk about
science nor scientist.
Nor the moon was on the list.
And not even fog
was on the list,
which is an important
word for people
who live in the Bay Area.
They talk about
fog all the time.
And you think, but why do I need
fog to describe the universe?
But it turns out that
the early universe
can be described as a sort
of fog, high energy fog.
But I couldn't use energy,
I couldn't use fog.
I could use high, but
that's not very good, right?
So what I needed to do
was to try and invent
a new set of vocabulary
really to be talking
about all there is with a
very different set of words.
And little by little a
new voice came together.
A voice that sort of came
out of the challenge itself.
And the book has
its own voice that
was a co-creation between
what I wanted to say
and what the lexicon--
the thousand word list--
allowed me to say.
And so a telescope
became a big seer.
The universe became
the all there is.
And plants became crazy
stars because they
go around projecting
motion on the sky.
The pattern of motion in
the sky is back and forth.
And so it's a crazy star.
It doesn't go around
like all of the stars.
Particles became drops.
Our planet, the Earth,
became our home world.
And scientists are
student people,
or student persons in the book.
The moon is the sun's sister.
Sun is on the list,
so I could use that.
And galaxies are star crowds.
Now, the Big Bang
was easy, I thought,
because I can't use a
bang but I can use flash.
And it was a hot beginning,
so I'll call it the hot flash.
But then my editor told me
that the hot flash was not
a good word to use for that.
And so I changed it to big
flash, so I learned something.
And so out of this
new vocabulary,
a new voice emerged.
A new way of looking at
the universe emerged.
And here, at the end of the
book, here's the cloud of words
that I ended up using.
707 words all together.
And you can see that
there's lots of dark,
because there's lots of dark
stuff in the book, dark energy,
dark matter.
Of course, the dark energy
is not called. that.
It's called the dark push.
People are mostly
student people,
that's to say scientists.
Drops for particles.
Away, far away is big, because
there's lots of faraway things.
Light, space, crazy-- for crazy
stars-- seer-- for big seer--
and so on.
And so really it becomes
a different language.
It's almost like
creating a new language
to talk about the things.
So today what I
want to do, I want
to share some of the bits of
the voice that came out of this
and also share some of the
science that's behind it.
But before I do so,
I wanted to give you
a little condensed
version of the book.
Each of the 10
chapters of the book
begins with a very short
haiku style three-liner
form of poetry.
So haiku is this
Japanese form of poetry
which is condensed in just
three verses, which is often
very imagery heavy
and very condensed.
And so it's just
a flash of words
that tries to evoke something.
And so I tried to
condense each chapter down
to just three lines.
And so there is 10 chapters.
And so in 85 words,
think of this
as the pseudo code to
the book if you like.
So that's a double-condensed
version of the universe.
So the book contains 707 words.
But actually, here is the
entire [INAUDIBLE] universe
in 85 words in this
double-condensed form.
"In the clear night, her
dark hair mirrors the stars.
Blue worlds going
around, points of light.
Behind the stars, space
time grows silent.
Hot kisses leave
light very tired.
Her pink lips stay dry
in the heavy dark rain.
A soft song might
tell you dark stories.
With the last breath,
and blushing of light
from faraway stars.
A silent end, times of
light half remembered.
So many worlds,
all that can be is.
Everything opens at the
smallest touch of a rose."
So that's the
[INAUDIBLE] of all there
is, the entire contents of the
book boiled down to 85 words.
It might be a little
bit too dense,
so let me unpack it for
you, and step back, and just
tell you a little bit the
storyline of the book.
Because the book story
came out as a conversation,
really, as a distillation
of hundreds of talks
that I'd given
before-- public talks
that I've given to all sorts of
people in different settings.
So the story came
very naturally to me.
I was very lucky that
I had already in mind
when I started writing the
book what I wanted to tell.
And it's a story that begins
with a student woman--
a fictional character-- here
she is, walking up to big seer.
There are two characters
really in this book.
One is the student woman who is
a student person who goes out
for the first time to one of
the biggest telescopes on earth,
big seer, for a
night of observation
to study dark matter and try to
crack the dark matter mystery.
So here she is
walking up to big seer
in this beautiful illustration
that accompanies the book.
I was very lucky
to have [INAUDIBLE]
a very talented young
artist and illustrator
who produced and created the
beautiful line drawings that
accompany the book.
And so, our student person,
she goes up to big seer.
Big seer is the second
character in his book.
It's the silent helper,
it's the big telescope
that helps her in
trying to unlock
the mysteries of dark matter.
So it's like a fictionalized
version of reality.
Of course, in reality
scientists do not
go out to telescopes on top
of mountains like Hawaii,
for example, working
alone at 12,000 feet
because that
wouldn't be possible.
But still, that's a
fictional version of reality
that allows us to follow
her night of observation
and her questions about the
all there is, the way it became
to be what it is today and all
the questions that we still
have about its nature
and its properties.
She in particular
is out there looking
for that matter, which is
one of the biggest mysteries
today and one that
can be probably solved
by science in the next five
years or so, or so we hope.
So our scientist goes out and
makes observations of the sky.
And what is she looking for?
Let's take a step back.
Here is a picture of
Edwin Hubble, 1927,
the discover of what is
now called Hubble's Law.
The fact that the
universe is expanding,
which Hubble discovered
by looking at distant star
crowds-- that's to say galaxies.
At the time they
were called nebulae.
People didn't know
what they were.
They didn't even know whether
they were inside or outside
the wide world-- that's to say
the Milky Way, our own galaxy.
But what Hubble discovered
was that he charted out
the velocity of those
distant star crowds
as a function of the
distance from us.
And so each one of those
dots is a measurement
that he took working
not far away from here
in southern California.
And what he saw, he realized
that as objects are further
away from us here, they're
also traveling at faster speeds
and are receding from us.
They're moving away from us.
And what he did, he
very boldly drew a line
through those points
and said, here
there is a linear relationship.
There is a relationship between
how far away objects are
and how far they're moving.
And the slope of this line here,
the slope of this relationship
is to do is day
called Hubble's Law.
And this Hubble's Law is telling
us that far away galaxies
are moving away from us
faster than nearby galaxies.
And this is only possible if the
entire universe is expanding.
In other words, the picture
that emerged from this discovery
is that galaxies are moving
away from each other.
And they're moving away
faster the further away
they are as a
consequence of the fact
that space time itself between
galaxies is stretching.
It's expanding just like the
pizza dough that we saw before.
But the astonishing
thing is that if we now
turn this thing upside down and
we look at time going backwards
in the backwards
direction, he thinks
if galaxies are moving
away from each other today,
this means that they were
together in the past--
or they were closer
by in the past.
And if you go even
further back in the past
they were closer together.
And if you can go even
further back in time,
there comes a point where all
these galaxies were heaped up
on top of each other, which
is what we call the Big Bang.
So the astonishing
discovery that Hubble
made almost 100
years ago now was
that the universe is expanding.
And it all came from an
initial hot, dense point
that we now call the Big Bang.
And so this was what
Hubble discovered
with only a handful
of observations,
maybe 30, 40
galaxies he measured.
That's all.
But nowadays of
course, our discipline
has moved on very much.
And so we are very
much entering the world
of big data, which is
something that people here
know a lot about of course.
And so you can see
here, this graph
is an extension of what
Hubble saw in 1927.
So Hubble only saw
this little corner here
of this diagram where he put
that line through these dots.
We have been now able
to extend this diagram
to much further distances.
And that's a picture
from the paper
that I quoted in the beginning,
the 1999 [INAUDIBLE] paper that
was awarded the Nobel Prize
for physics a few years ago.
And this was the status in 1999.
In 2010 you can see how many
more data points we have,
and how this expansion
of the universe
is being charted out with
greater and greater precision.
Here are observations of the
relic radiation from the Big
Bang, the remnants
of the Big Bang.
In 1994 the discovery of the
microwave echo of the Big Bang
with the COBE satellite.
Again, Nobel Prize for physics.
2001 the WMAP satellite
measures the same radiation
but with a much
higher resolution.
And now the Planck satellite,
the latest instrument,
has observed the sky with
even greater resolution.
We can see how many
more details we
can see from this light
that comes straight
from the Big Bang.
Here galaxies in the sky.
In 1985 there was a state of
the art 1,100 galaxies observed.
Each one of those dots
is a galaxy on the sky.
And this is the state of the
art today, one million galaxies
from the [INAUDIBLE] Sky Survey.
Each one of those
colored dots is a galaxy.
And when the square
kilometer array
comes online in
about 10 years time--
which will be an array of
radio telescope spread over two
continents-- we'll measure
the position and distance
of tens of millions of
galaxies in the sky.
So this is what big data
now means in our field.
And what have we learned?
So let's have a look
at a patch of the sky.
Let's have a look at the
patch of the sky which
is pictured here.
So you can see here,
there's the full moon.
The full moon is about
half a degree on the sky
if you look at it from here.
And everybody knows
what the full moon
looks like on the sky.
And here is a little
patch of that same sky
in which is singled
out this yellow square.
So this is a tiny
little patch of the sky.
To give you an idea of how
small this yellow square is,
it is the same
amount of sky that
would fit inside the eye of a
needle held at arm's length.
So it's tiny.
And yet if you look at it with
the most powerful telescopes
that we have, the
Hubble Space Telescope,
this is what you see.
There are 505,000 galaxies
inside that eye of the needle.
And each one of those galaxies
contains about 100 billion
stars, just like the
Milky Way, our galaxy,
contains about a few
hundred billion stars.
And if I zoom in, you can see
that each one of those dots
indeed is a galaxy.
You can see beautiful
spiral galaxies,
and you can see other more
regularly shaped galaxies,
and so on and so forth.
And so all of those
galaxies, they
fit within this eye of a needle.
So you can imagine
how many more there
are in the entire universe
as we cover the entire sky.
And yet, perhaps the most
astonishing discovery
of modern cosmology
is that this is only
a fraction of what is out there.
So the headline news is
that 96% of the universe
is actually missing.
So what is this dark
side of the universe?
What is all the rest that's
out there that does not show up
in that picture and doesn't
show up in any of the pictures?
Well, we now know that the
luminous matter-- stars
and luminous galaxies--
this tiny little sliver
of the cosmic sky, this
tiny little bit here,
all the rest here,
the red bit here
is other non-luminous
components in the form
of intergalactic
gas, and neutrinos,
and super massive black
holes, and so on, which
is all stuff that's
made of particles that
are the same kind of particles
that we are made off.
So this part here is the
tiny fraction of the universe
that we know about.
But the largest
majority of the universe
is made of dark, invisible,
unknown, as of yet undiscovered
stuff.
Dark matter 23% or so of
the universe and dark energy
the biggest part of the pie.
What in the book is
called dark push.
And so one of the biggest
mysteries of cosmology
is precisely to try and work out
what this 95% of the universe
is made of.
What is the fundamental
nature of all the stuff
that we don't know about?
But fortunately,
we now have means
of doing that with
data, with very
sophisticated observations.
Remember, cosmology
is a time machine.
In other words, the
speed of light is finite.
And being finite, it means
that the further out you
look in the universe, the
further back in time you see.
Because light takes time
to travel from the furthest
objects to us.
300,000 kilometers per
second is the speed of light,
so every time you look at the
sun, you're looking at the sun
not as it is now but
you're looking at the sun
as it was eight minutes ago
because that's how long it
takes for light to cover the 150
million kilometers between us
and the sun.
So if you look at
distant galaxies,
you see them not as they
are "now", quote, unquote,
but as they were
billions of years
ago when that light first left.
And so if you look back
further out in space,
if you use the Hubble
Space Telescope,
that's pretty much how far back
in space and time we can look,
a few billion years ago.
But if you use different types
of light, like microwave light
and microwave satellites, we
can go back all the way almost
to the Big Bang.
And so we can pick up light
that left just 380,000 years
after the Big Bang, which is
the end of the visible universe.
And this is what we see.
This is a picture of the
sky taken in microwaves.
And that's a picture that
shows the baby universe.
This light left
when the universe
was a tiny, tiny fraction
of its current age.
The current age of the universe
is about 13.7 billion years,
and this light has
been en route almost
since the very beginning.
And what you see
here is a picture
of the universe where
there are no galaxies yet,
because there was no time
for galaxies to form.
No stars yet.
All there is is matter, light,
photons, and dark matter.
What you see here
is the red spots
are spots of slightly larger
concentration of energy,
and light, and matter, which
are the seeds of what then will
become galaxies such
as the Milky Way.
And so this picture here is the
end of the visible universe.
And I don't mean
it as a metaphor,
I mean it as a
scientific statement
because there's no way we
can see past this picture.
The universe was opaque
to light before this time,
because it was too energetic
for light to travel freely.
Light kept bouncing off
electrons and protons
in the early universe.
And so this early universe
picture, which we can see,
can be described
as a sort of fog.
It was a high energy fog,
2,000 Kelvin temperature.
So almost 2,000 degrees Celsius.
But in the book, of course,
I couldn't talk about it
in terms of fog, because there
is no fog in the list of words.
So here's how this
early universe picture
is described using
the thousand words.
"It was like when you look out
your window on a cold morning.
There's ice on the road,
and everything looks gray,
and you can't see
past your driveway.
This is because light gets
kicked about by tiny water
drops in the air before
reaching your eyes.
Something like
this was happening
at that time", that's to
say, at the very beginning,
"only everything was 100 times
hotter than on a hot summer's
day.
And so this is just
a simple description
of what the universe looked
like at the very beginning.
And then things started
to change, and evolve,
and galaxies grew out of it.
And gravity started
doing its job.
And gravity, as I told you
before, is not at all a force.
It's just a reflection on
the shape of space time.
So here's how this
can be described
using the thousand
words lexicon.
So this is a crash course in
generativity in one paragraph
and less than 1,000
words in English.
So talking about Einstein here
and how he thought gravity
was different from
Newton's gravity.
"He", that's to
say Mr. Einstein,
"then asked himself,
what would happen
if you put some heavy
stuff-- as heavy
as a star in the
middle of space time?
He was the first to understand
that matter puts in space
time and changes
the way it looks.
In turn, the form
of space time is
what moves matter
one way or another.
As an idea, this was
very different from what
Mr. Newton had said
a long time ago.
For Mr. Newton, space and time
did not talk to each other,
never married, and
lived different lives."
And then it goes on
describing how this idea could
be tested using a solar
eclipse, because of course
exceptional claims need
exceptional means of evidence.
And so in 1919 Einstein's
idea of generativity
was proven proven right by
observations of a solar eclipse
here in one of the illustrations
of the book that actually
proved that light was
being moved around
and changing trajectory
along the bent space
time exactly like
Einstein predicted.
So here is the backdrop of
what the student person is
trying to do with
our observations.
And all of these observations
that I told you about,
they paint a very strange
picture of the universe.
A picture of the
universe where again we
have a very puzzling
universe, a universe where
we have dark matter, again
these omega numbers that make it
look as if we know what we're
talking about-- but in reality
we just hide our ignorance
behind Greek letters.
And so the amount of dark matter
that there is in the universe
has been now measured
very precisely
using its gravitational
effect in the cosmos,
about 26.6% with a
few percent around it.
And then there's
another, and possibly
a new type of particle beyond
[INAUDIBLE] particle physics.
And then there is dark
energy, the dark push,
the mysterious force that's
making the universe expand
faster and faster all the time,
which makes up 70% or more
68.6% of the universe.
And those two things together
are very much mysterious.
We don't know what they are.
One thing we've learned
actually very precisely,
which is the age
of the universe.
Now the age of the universe
is 13,798,000 years,
which is astonishing
to be able to quote
this figure within a margin of
error of 37 million years only.
That's nothing at all.
I mean, we sit on the
earth, it's right here,
and yet we don't know the age
of the earth with precision.
And we can tell the
age of the universe
with incredible accuracy.
It's an accuracy that's
really astonishing.
Let's put this into
perspective with 1,000 words.
"This is really
great if you think
how long ago the
big flash happened.
It was over 100 times 100
times 100 times 100 times
100 years ago.
We know the age of
the order so well
that it would be like
being able to tell
the day of the year a
stranger in the street
came to life to the nearest
day just by looking at him."
And that's one of the great
discoveries of cosmology
that comes out of mapping
out the tiny ripples
in the microwave radiation in
the voluminous echo of the Big
Bang we were talking
about before.
And I don't want to go into
details of the technicalities,
but I do want to show
you one picture that's
quite astonishing, I think.
It's slightly
technical, but again I
think people here will
appreciate the idea of data
compression and how we can
compress a large amount of data
into just a few numbers.
So here we have our micro
satellite sending down
a stream of data, a
stream of points, 10
to the 12 bits of data that go
into making this map of the sky
that I told you before, 50
million pixels that then gets
reduced by statistical
massaging into a plot which
has got 2,500
measurements points on it.
And this plot how much
fluctuations there
are on this map as
a function of scale.
It doesn't really matter
the technical details,
but what I want to
show you is this plot,
which is derived from the
microwave [INAUDIBLE] map,
the map of the light
from the Big Bang.
And you can see the data
points here which are in red.
And they follow a very
interesting oscillatory
wave-like pattern,
a pattern that we
can understand using [INAUDIBLE]
level physics in very
great detail, because this is
physics of the universe which
we understand with
very high precision.
And this is proven by the
fact that we can-- right now
the theoretical model, a theory
of the universe, of the all
there is, that contains
three different ingredients.
One is Einstein
generativity, the other one
is the Big Bang as a
theory, and the other one
is these dark components--
dark matter, dark energy,
or the dark push as I put it.
And you could see that this
theoretical model, which
has got only six numbers
in it, six free parameters,
is the green line.
It goes through the
observations almost perfectly.
So we understand the
observation incredibly well,
all the way if we extend
the horizontal axis,
we understand them all the
way to the smallest details
down here, down into this
tail of distribution.
And so what I want
to say with this
is that we have this
incredible wealth
of data about the universe.
We've got these incredible
sophisticated models.
And yet, to make them work, to
make the models match the data,
we need these two
unknown ingredients.
We need dark matter,
we need dark energy,
and we don't know what they are.
And this is one of the
biggest quests at the moment.
So how does our
student person go
about understanding dark
matter and dark energy?
So during her night
of observations
she is thinking about
those mysteries,
and how they are
very much unsolved,
and what we can do to try
and understand them better.
So when she casts her mind's
eye back to the dark push,
this is what goes
on in her mind.
"She steps outside
in the cold night,
holding her cup of hot
coffee with both hands.
The wide world is beautiful,
the dark clear sky.
And once again, she can't
help but be amazed by it all.
It doesn't matter how many
times she's seen this before
or how much she knows
about what is out there.
The site of the stars is
enough to make her gasp.
It all seems so still, and yet
it's changing all the time,
she whispers to no one.
It is hard to believe
that everything out there
past the wide world and it
starts is running away from us.
Yet, like Mr. Hubble
found long ago,
the star crowds are running
away from each other
at the space between them
gets bigger and bigger.
The all there is is
growing with time."
And that's what the dark
push or dark energy is doing.
A repulsive force,
possibly a new type
of a vacuum energy-- and energy
associated with empty space
itself-- that's
pushing things apart.
And the big mystery is that
this dark energy not only
is something that we don't
understand fundamentally,
it's something that could even
be pointing to what I call
the dark side of the universe
here, because one of the ideas
to explain the existence
of this dark push
is to postulate the
existence of a multiverse.
A grander scheme
of reality in which
we are but only but a
tiny little bit of what
is out there.
So the all there is, all the
stuff that I told you about--
and this is very
speculative, but it's
just one of the ideas
that can be invoked
to explain the origin of the
dark push or dark energy.
So the idea is that all there is
is only a tiny fraction of what
reality is actually made of.
That our universe
itself, presumably
of infinite spatial
extent, is but a tiny bit
of a grander reality
called the multiverse which
is depicted here by
these different bubbles.
And these different bubbles
represent different corners
of the multiverse,
each one of them
with different laws of physics.
And those laws of physics
varying across the multiverse
that could explain why
our universe appears
to be so strange with a dark
energy content that appears
to be strangely
fine tuned for life
to be able to exist
in our universe.
And so this is what is called
the entropic principle,
the idea that we live in a
corner of the multiverse that's
good for life not because
our universe is strangely
fine tuned, but because we
as biological life forms
need for a long-leaved
cold universe
with a stable rocky planet
going around a star.
We must be in a corner
of the multiverse
where the fundamental
constants of nature
are such that will allow this
kind of ecosystem to emerge.
And so if we had a larger
reality like the multiverse
with a large number of
possible universes to try life,
we'd only be found in a corner
of the multiverse that's
just right, and therefore that
would appear fine tuned to us.
So here's the idea of the
multiverse, a collection
of perhaps up to 10 to the
500 parallel universes, which
is this spectacularly large
number of parallel universes,
each one of them with
different laws of physics
and different ways of mixing
the constants of nature.
And we will be found in one
special place, a place where
everything is just
right for us to exist.
Not us as human beings, but
as examples of biological life
forms that need very
special conditions.
And so these are
all ideas that go on
in the mind of our heroine,
the student woman that
at the end of her night is
quite happy with the way
her observations have gone.
With the help of
big seer, she has
looked as far away as
she possibly could.
And she has gathered a lot
of data about dark matter
that she hopes to be able
to decrypt and understand
in order to crack this mystery.
And so this is
how her night ends
and this is how this talk ends.
"She sits down.
The big blue body of
water in front of her
seems to go on without
edges and without end.
She can feel the warm hand
of the sun on her face.
She feels happy.
The night's work has gone well.
Big seer has done a great job,
the best that could be done.
She can go home now.
But her job has only just begun.
There is much more left to do
in the coming weeks and months
before she could make sense of
what big seer saw last night.
She is looking forward to it.
Letters, and words,
and entire books
are hidden in what big
seer has given her, written
in the strange tongue
of the all there is.
Little by little,
she will understand
it better and better.
All she needs to do is
ask the right questions
in the right way, and she
might learn the truth.
She smiles and the sun
smiles back at her."
So thank you very much
for having me here today.
It's been a great
pleasure, and I
am very happy to
take your questions.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: So I was kind of
surprised to see that matter
was one of the thousand words
but things like fog was not.
And so I wondered,
maybe there might
be a case of a
simple homonym where
it's matter as in subject
or something like that.
So do you think but the
presence of-- I don't know,
maybe matter is the
only one-- but do
you think that having
a homonym that you're
using for a more
abstract concept when
in the 1,000-- most likely
it's probably not used
in that case-- do you
think that that works
against the general concept
of speaking simply like that?
ROBERTO TROTTA: Yeah, I think
that's a very good question.
The [INAUDIBLE] question is,
where does the list of words
come from and which list
should one use, right?
So I started using
the same list that
had been used for
the [INAUDIBLE],
just because it started as an
experimental project very much.
And then later on when
the book became something
of more substance,
at least to me,
I started asking myself
those very same questions.
Where do those words come from?
And what happens if I
use a different list?
And which source
should I use to compile
these lists is the first place?
And certainly to
a certain level,
which kind of source you use to
compile the list will influence
which words make it into the
top 1,000 and which don't.
And therefore this
might give you
more abstract or less
abstract words to play with.
And so to an extent, yes, this
is a relevant question to ask.
But in the end I came
around view that in a sense
it doesn't really matter
which words are on the list.
Any set of rules is arbitrary
to an extent, and so are mine.
So I wasn't that much
interested in getting
the absolute top 1,000 most used
words in any specific context.
What I was interested in was,
given a set of 1,000 words
and a set of somewhat
arbitrary rules-- for example
I'm allowing myself to use
names of people but not names
of cities, just because I
thought that names of people
would be hard to
go around and it
would be a pointless exercise
of style in doing so.
But names of cities
could be a fun thing
to work with if you
don't have them.
And so given that
set of rules, it
was interesting seeing
what kind of voice,
what kind of different
approach to thinking
about those concepts emerged.
And so, yes possibly
a different list
would make the exercise
harder or easier perhaps.
But the point is
that any list will
have words that are
missing from it.
And so the question is,
how do you get around it?
And what kind of
different approach?
My hope is that the voice
that emerges from the exercise
will be novel, and surprising,
and new, and refreshing,
even if some words
that are missing
should be there perhaps,
or shouldn't be there.
My point is just to take a
new approach to this subject
and see whether or not
this can speak to people.
And what people can
take away from it.
AUDIENCE: Very
interesting, thank you.
AUDIENCE: So you
explain why you're
using the 1,000 words as
opposed to another number.
But once you've
finished all this,
do you think that maybe
if you had 10,000,
you would have been able to do
a better job not getting too far
away from your message
without using words
that people would not
understand necessarily?
ROBERTO TROTTA: Right.
I found actually that 1,000
words was a very interesting
sweet spot, because
I looked at the list
and the list goes
up to 2,000 words.
So I don't know
about 10,000 words.
But even if you
go to 2,000 words,
that list is quite
comprehensive.
In fact, lots of words
that I couldn't use
are in the 2,000 words.
Like energy, for example, and
force is in the top 2,000,
and so on.
And so 2,000 words is
almost too long a list,
because it doesn't impose
enough of a straitjacket
on your expression, I think.
If you make it too
easy for yourself,
then the experimental side
of the language playfulness
is lost, in a sense,
because you got almost
all the words you'd wish
for-- except perhaps
for redshift or technical
words that you don't want
to use because they are
jargony and that's fine.
But 2,000 words
would be already too
big a list to impose any
meaningful restrictions
on your way of
expressing yourself.
On other hand, 500
words would be too few.
And you couldn't make
it work, I don't think,
with 500 because it
becomes too hard.
And it becomes really cumbersome
to say almost anything
with only 500.
So 1,000 words is actually
a nice sweet spot.
And it hard enough,
but not impossible.
And I think if you
tweak it to either side,
you might find that it becomes
either too easy-- in which case
you fall back to a standard
way of expressing almost
those concepts-- or
too hard, in which case
it becomes more of an exercise
in style, which this one is
only to a certain extent.
The purpose of this is not
to be an exercise in style.
It's to really talk
about things in a way
that people will understand.
And this is my hope.
And it's up to my readers to see
whether I've succeeded or not.
And that's why I'm also very
keen to hear from people what
they think, whether it
works for them or not.
So that's very much an
experiment on my side.
AUDIENCE: So [INAUDIBLE]
universe expanding.
The part I wasn't
too clear about
is whether-- I've
read in some places
that the medium that
the universe is in
could actually be expanding in
addition to the galaxies moving
away from one another, which
means that it could move faster
than the speed of light since
whatever it is sitting on
is actually moving or
stretching at the same time.
Can you explain a
bit more about that?
ROBERTO TROTTA:
So there's a lots
of confusion about this
barrier of the speed of light.
Some people mistakenly think
that-- because as we know,
the speed of light is the
ultimate speed limit--
galaxies cannot move away
from each other faster than
the speed of light.
That is plain wrong.
Galaxies do move faster
away from each other
than the speed of light.
And they do so routinely.
In fact, there is a large
number of the galaxies
that we saw on that slide
that are moving away
from us at faster than the speed
of light and always have been.
Now that's a tricky bit,
because we think, well actually
if those galaxies are
moving away faster
than the speed of light, how
is it that we can see them?
How is it that light can catch
up with us in the first place?
So that's something that's
slightly counter intuitive
about it, and it cannot
be explained except with
generativity.
So analogies such as if you
go downstream and the stream
is faster, then you can
swim upward, upstream, you
will never catch up [INAUDIBLE].
And those analogies do
not work in cosmology
because of generativity.
So galaxies do move away
faster than the speed of light.
But the point is
that it's not them
moving in space faster
than the speed of light.
It's the space
between them that's
expanding faster than
the speed of light.
So that doesn't break the
speed of light barrier,
because the speed
of light barrier
is for objects inside
space time to have
so-called peculiar velocities--
that's to say velocities
inside space time moving
from one place to another.
But because it's
space time itself,
the pizza dough if you like
in the analogy is expanding.
The recession speed,
the speed at which
are bolted onto space time are
moving away from each other
can be faster than
the speed of light.
And so that is a misconception
the things cannot move farther
away than the speed of light.
They do, and we observe
them all the time.
AUDIENCE: I know.
Every time I see
the WMAP picture,
I'm trying to understand,
why does it have its shape?
And what does it
really represent?
Does it represent anything
that's moving away from us?
And obviously,
things coming with us
we'd be able to see the
one closer to us as opposed
to seeing it how it was
13 billion years ago.
ROBERTO TROTTA: You mean the
microwave background picture?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
ROBERTO TROTTA: So the
microwave background
picture-- this picture
here-- is actually
a-- think of this as a
picture taken on a screen.
So this picture here
is-- all the light
that comes from this picture
has been emitted 380,000
years after the Big Bang, and
it has been traveling ever
since through the universe.
So this is like a
snapshot-- literally it's
a snapshot of what the universe
looked like at that time.
So by shape, do you mean the
shape of the picture itself
or the shape of
the blobs inside.
AUDIENCE: No, the
shape of the picture.
And the thing is, for us to see
13 billion years in the past,
we have to be 13 billion
light years away from it?
Or not?
ROBERTO TROTTA: That's
right, absolutely.
Yeah, even more, I
mean, because of course
13 billion light years
is a ton of time.
But in the meantime,
in this time,
the part of space from
which this light has left
has been expanded away.
So the current
distance to this part
is much more, about 45
billion light years, in fact.
AUDIENCE: Is all of that stuff
that's moving away from us
today?
Or some of it actually
is moving our direction?
ROBERTO TROTTA: No, all of
this would be moving away,
because it's so far away
that it will be moving away.
AUDIENCE: That's why
we're seeing it now.
Otherwise we wouldn't be
seeing it that far in the past.
ROBERTO TROTTA: Well, you
would see the things now,
after the light travel time
independent of whether they're
moving away or
moving towards us,
just because of the initial
distance between them and us.
And then the light beam
leaves, and then it
travels through space time.
And whatever the initial source
is doing is then independent.
So it's just the time
that it takes for light
to travel across the space time.
And so that's how the
connection between us
and this distant
part of space is
purely given by the
light travel time
that it takes for a beam of
light to go from there to now.
AUDIENCE: Oh, so something
that could emit light
back then-- because
you just said
can move faster than
the speed of light,
because of the medium.
ROBERTO TROTTA: That's right.
It would be recessed
away from us faster
than the speed of
light in the meantime.
But the light all the while
is catching up with us.
So we will see the
picture of that
object as it goes
at the moment when
the light had been emitted.
AUDIENCE: And the reason
for that actual shape.
Why does the shape--
ROBERTO TROTTA: OK,
shape is just the fact
that we're looking at the
entire sky, all around us.
And so sometimes
we see the shape
in the shape of a
balloon, which would
be the shape of the
sky like when you have
a normal constellation
type of balloon
with all the constellations
painted on it.
And then what you do,
you cut this balloon
across one of the great
circles, and lie down flat,
and this is what you see.
This is just a picture
of the entire 360 degrees
sphere of the sky around us cut
along one of the [INAUDIBLE]
lie down flat on paper.
AUDIENCE: So where would the
earth be on that picture?
ROBERTO TROTTA: At the center.
At the center.
It's wrapped around us.
AUDIENCE: That's how
it's put on picture.
OK.
SPEAKER 1: thank Roberto again.
ROBERTO TROTTA:
Thank you. [APPLAUSE]